[Applause]
last year art enthusiasts were left
speechless when a painting by Banksy was
left in tatters moments afterwards sold
at Sotheby's for 1.4 million dollars
turns out the subversive British Street
artists had planted a shredder inside
the frame it was perhaps the most
infamous sale held by the historic
London auction house but for centuries
Sotheby's has been at the crossroads of
art and commerce selling off countless
works for record sons as the venerable
firm marks its 270 fifth-year Roxana
Saberi has a look at its past and its
presence at eight million five hundred
thousand with a mix of suspense Alex are
we gonna come in congratulations so
soaring prices and glamour
Sotheby's has turned into one of the top
fine art auction houses in the world but
what's now a four billion dollar
business in 40 countries at a very warm
welcome to Sotheby's London putting on
more than 400 auctions a year started
with the sale of scarce second-hand
books in London 275 years ago the man
wielding the first gavel was Samuel
Baker a bookseller and the company's
founder through the centuries sudden B's
expanded from aristocratic libraries
into jewelry estates and art when I came
to Sotheby's there were 120 employees
Marcus Llanelli Sotheby's
longest-serving employee joined the
auction house in 1956 as a 16 year old
trainee two years later he snuck into
what turned out to be the biggest sale
yet in the company's history and the
room was totally packed with celebrities
need I say nearly two million dollars
worth of paintings gone in just 21
minutes there was a man a a Monet Renoir
and they were just web stunning pictures
in recent decades
Sotheby's has brought in record prices
for other masterpieces classic and
contemporary and it sold the private
collections of icons such as Elton John
David Bowie and Jacqueline Kennedy
Onassis Oliver Barker has overseen some
of Sotheby's most prestigious
ladies and gentlemen a masterpiece by
jean-michel basquiat like the 2017 sale
of this painting by jean-michel Basquiat
fair warning and selling thank you sir
for 98 million dollars this is an artist
who was never collected by American
institutions during his lifetime which
tells you a lot about black American art
as well this felt like an absolutely
transformative moment 1,100,000
1,200,000 one rain-free parker says
after more than 20 years as an
auctioneer you know safety net and
strange things can happen too when he
sold a painting by the street artist
banksy for nearly a million and a half
dollars and it started falling through
its frame merging in shreds I remember I
achieve this this alarm going off and
subliminally just thinking out is that a
fire alarm or you know do we need to
safely evacuate everybody in the
audience from the room ultimately I
realized immediately if this had to be
Banksy it had to be you know a stunt
that he pulled basically over the years
Sotheby's has survived controversies in
2002 it was fined for colluding with the
world's other leading auction house
Christie's to fix commission fees it's
also been fighting the image that it's
old-school and elitist can somebody like
me who doesn't have a ton of money buy
anything off of Sotheby's yes absolutely
like but you do need enough money to buy
it
is one possibility I could buy something
for $60 yes not very often I have to say
still anyone can look at the items up
close before they hit the auction block
at free exhibitions online bidding has
also helps the bees reach more people we
talk about now somebody's being a
start-up it's like a two hundred and
seventy five year old startup but that
is abundantly true well the world of
auctions is transforming Linnell says
their essence remains timeless these
items bring joy to people's lives I do
think they do yes
is that why this job brings joy to you
oh I'm sending to you sir for CBS this
morning Saturday Roxana Saberi
London thank you very much have you ever
been to one of these auction oh oh my
god they are just exhilarating to sit
there and I was over at Christie's and I
attempted to make a bid on something
with a tour friend it was not $60 I want
to know what sold for $60 that somebody
could actually seriously yeah and we
hope proc Santa gets it yeah wonders
Roxanna get on it